[Music]
and fix my brain new yes please nope
okay submitted by Bart Kwanza hmm a
small study suggests that magic
mushrooms can reset a depressed brain I
know some depressing ask people that
need that [ __ ] dude
give them some mushrooms and they'll
just stop complaining I know they're
clinically depressed but they say
they're depressed a lot so let's get
miss mushrooms like babies gotta bring
everyone else down yeah I never did
shrooms maybe it'll help me but you'd
have to press no bro
I like acid it was fun it was too much I
never tried shrooms
I tried to focus when I was 19 you
coming down now I'm good but if has
never done drugs Isaac and she did I'm
pretty sure it's when she was in her
early years way before Isaac it was all
right before you shut the [ __ ] up
I thought they were truffles - yeah it
was on accident [ __ ] even know what it
was she was a virgin when she had you
she your mom never had sex let's go
who hasn't ADA shitake mushroom so there
was a small study published in the
journal scientific reports and so the
study gave 19 patients that have like
untreatable depression a single dose of
a psychedelic ingredient silo semen silo
see so that's what that ingredient is
and so that ingredient is in shrimps and
so they're saying that half of the
patients completely ceased to be
depressed and experienced changes in
their brain activity that lasted about
five weeks Wow need it again cuz their
gifts had no eyes no I just completely
made them stop being do what
but then the changes in their brain
activity lasted about five weeks but so
they're saying that this the Silas
then has a role by acting sort of like
lubricant a lubricant for the mind and
so those gears going yeah it allows
wd-40 for your brain bowl I want to do
it it allows people to just get out of
that cycle of depressive and you know
somebody who I'm gonna give him [ __ ]
shrooms because every time I see him
he's [ __ ] sad as [ __ ] [ __ ] about
everything would tell me shut the [ __ ]
up and [ __ ] shove that mushroom in
his day I wish the mushrooms so every
time I hear mushrooms that drug I always
think of the [ __ ] Portobello no no I
think of the Mario mushroom she was like
that or like [ __ ] Alice in Wonderland
mushrooms it looked like drugs [ __ ] like
they tasted like honey look how cute
like a cute probably bad idea in a
peanut butter and jelly sandwich and
just eat it I had a lot dippin II do but
if you were you would have aesthetically
speaking ragout with the banana for
dessert and it was delicious on a date
with Casey this was a study right so I'm
assuming that they regulated the dosage
yeah that's what I do I'm just a single
dosage okay yeah and so they are also
stressing that they do not recommend
people to just taking shrooms where can
I go to try it they just have to say
that but I think he sounds like he wants
to do it no no not to be impressed no no
not for me for my fans
he's addressing ninja Malians from a fan
[Laughter]
I'm not trying to condone any type of
drug usage I'm always against things
that are illegal but in the countries
that are legal your eyes tell me
otherwise we have fans that are from the
Netherlands or two to three hundred
balls oh yeah nether land people know I
looked at Jess's 23andme she's like
200-300 niandra Polly she's from that
area oh [ __ ] I got a Dubai it had the
kid at home [ __ ] but anyways okay
beyond the caveman history stuff in
places that are legal just saying if
they need to figure out how much shrooms
they need because I'm against that
antidepressant [ __ ] that's what I'm
really against that makes people crazy
yeah I know that's true I'd rather have
somebody smoked some weed before they go
ahead and pop some what him it goes what
are the names like there's a there's a
really popular ADHD one its prozac or
antidepressants you know yeah anyways
those [ __ ] people up really yeah they
[ __ ] people up how come the dude that I
know that takes antidepressants became
worse after he took it sometimes its
adverse you wanted more attention that's
why perhaps well because you become
addicted to it and then if you don't
have it your brain [ __ ] crashes hard
balance in your brain or he was sad but
at least he had energy and then he could
snap in and out of it now he's just kind
of like before the drugs when they were
depressed
that's the problem with drugs like that
because it makes him feel empty like a
shell of a person they're all their
emotions there when they are gone it
just keeps them going
I dunno should not be when my mom she
gave me like some ant eggs I'm like why
are you pointing at me
Ritalin but I wasn't ruined rewind
you're telling me that you would have
been just as crazy as us if you weren't
on the drug yeah what up because I took
it only for one month and my mom made me
stop cuz she's like you turn into a
complete zombie i neva recognize I got
every cent imagine if all [ __ ]
bouncing off the walls and a very small
firecracker friend that's always maybe
like somewhere in between where I am now
and that like I was there oh I [ __ ]
hated that person's guts too so I know
aloes crazier I just don't have memory
of it because I lived in the moment I
heard that shrooms are also good for
cluster headaches have you ever heard of
cluster honey oh dude my friend had this
right but cluster headaches is imagine
having a headache so bad that you're
curling on the floor crying that was a
migraine
no like imagine that that was just girl
but you imagine migraines but like worse
my friends I get 6 foot 2 something he
had cluster headaches and Zee white no
Asian oh and it's like what about ready
why people have a lot of other problems
that I've never heard of yeah like a
white people drugstore like rite aid
those roll rows of [ __ ] you go to an
Asian drug store and it's like Tiger
Balm ginseng and ginger [ __ ]
pharmaceutical companies can't make as
much money and they don't believe like
the Asian community believes more we
just ate a bunch of [ __ ] and on top
of that others don't take care of them
yeah why we don't even know that it
existed like for example I didn't even
know what allergies was I just kept
blowing my nose all the time and then
but now I have discovered the white
luxury of Zurich and now I don't blow my
nose BAM when you were growing up
[ __ ] the white people were taking
zyrtec they stopped but what you were
doing is [ __ ] taking turtle shout I
didn't do [ __ ] that's true I always got
jealous because all my white friends if
they had if they were sick they were
they didn't go to school their parents
took took care of them all that [ __ ] in
my ass mama was like if you're not dying
you still go to school dude I'm just
easing up on everybody and [ __ ] I'm
miserable
I just gotta remember well I know as
well as finishing um mushrooms help with
coaster headaches anyways you just
[ __ ] brought back in memory that I've
surprised that I traumatize you know or
bring back some trouble okay my
grandmother used to make me drink the
[ __ ] herbal [ __ ] and I remember the
[ __ ] clay pot thingy that they cook
it in oh yeah yeah yeah yeah and then
like they blank it over and they make me
sit in it oh wow like it seems a room
I'm like please I just want to get out
like it steams it out and he needs a
drink
grandma I'm so happy that we found out
what pepto-bismol was cuz any time I had
a [ __ ] stomachache they will grind up
I don't even know how they had charcoal
okay we had wood [ __ ] Charlie yeah
they ground up and then they put that
[ __ ] in water mix it up and I could
drink that [ __ ] see the decision and why
I'm so Bismol is charcoal has helped
that's what pepto is yeah don't have
charcoal right yeah is your boot black I
dream pepto like it's [ __ ] bubble gum
water
[Laughter]
do you know the big league chew
yeah it's like bubblegum like it looks
like melted bubblegum but it's water I
don't even know what's funny
hey guys thanks for watching that last
episode did you love it yes you did so
don't forget to subscribe this is first
time you're here
we've upload every single day so don't
miss an upload now to watch more
episodes check them out up here
[Music]